all right so this is a GPU that a lot of
you have been waiting for this is AMD's
new RX 5500 xt that launches today
priced between 170 and 200 u.s. dollars
we'll talk about that in a moment and
right in time for the holiday season now
at that price performance is going to be
seriously interesting because it's going
up against so many already great value
options actually it does feel like
forever since AMD launched a GPU in this
price range that wasn't just a refresh
of something else
so the 5500 xt is a highly anticipated
GPU and if the 5700 xt was anything to
go off performance here should be really
impressive so let's not waste any more
time let's take a quick look at the
specs and then see how the same performs
in games
[Music]
one thing that I'll mention right off
the bat is that the 5500 XD will be
available in both an 8 gigabyte model
and a lower-priced
4 gigabyte model that has a base MSRP of
169 US dollars thankfully there's no
trickery or sneaky tactics going on
between these two models like we've seen
before
both the 4 gigabyte and a gigabyte 5500
XTS will have the same number of compute
units and other wise processing power
it's just the video memory capacity that
will be different
so if bumping up your in-game textures
to ultra in demanding titles is
something that you are after the 8
gigabyte model is likely a good idea but
if you play mostly mainstream or eSports
titles with moderate to high ish
textures then the 4 gigabyte model will
offer the better value here's a quick
look at what we're working with the 5500
XD has 22 compute units compared to the
36 and 40 on the 50 750 700 xt
respectively so quite a significant cut
that's fair enough though given the also
massive cut in price the 5500 XT also
gets a narrower memory interface in
comparison but still thankfully fast GDD
are 6 in fact Nvidia didn't want to miss
out on this G DDR 6 memory party so they
invited themselves with the recent gtx
1650 super and 1660 super GPUs both are
considered competitors to the 5500 XT
the 1650 super unfortunately we do not
have on hand for testing it just yet
also worth noting as far as I know
AMD are not producing their own
reference our cooler design like they
have with the 50 750 700 XD so your
choice will be limited to a Dinn board
partner cards only now the one that I've
got here is Emma size at gaming X and as
usual they have sampled me with the more
premium model despite this being a
budget oriented card and as usual you
can expect to pay a premium for a cooler
design like this given that the 5500 XT
only has a 130 watt TDP though I'd say
you're going to be more than fine with
one of the more affordable models out
there with a more conservative cooler
design in terms of thermal performance
the gaming X topped out at 74 degrees C
on the GPU 84 C for the hotspot and 70s
six degrees C for the memory hotspot
this is with the fan speed set to auto
on an open Testament with a 22 C room
ambient overall acceptable thermals with
a fairly conservative and near silent
fan speed all right now let's jump into
the gaming benchmarks and starting with
far cry 5 we're seeing overall some
pretty decent gaming performance again
we are looking at the $200 a gigabyte
model today but given that it's just a
video memory capacity difference between
this and the 4 gigabyte model the
numbers should be very very close we're
vrm isn't maxed out here the 5500 XT is
a little over 5% faster than the rx 590
in overwatch the margin is a bit closer
between those two cards and for
reference the RX 590 can currently be
bought for around $200 even so really
these performance numbers are looking ok
so far for the 5500 XT Rainbow six siege
played decently for the new AMD card
with strong lowest 1% of FPS performance
and averages about on par with the rx
590 apex legend showed promising
performance for the 5500 XD again
specifically when it comes to the
overall stability of the framerate in
game he we're 7.8 percent faster than
the RX 590 on average and within 6
percent of the GTX 1660 and a similar
story in Doom running the Vulkan API
within just a few percent of the $220
gtx 1660 in comparison to the 1660 super
in this title you'll need to spend an
additional thirty to sixty dollars for a
boost of around 11 percent over the 5500
XT again the four gigabyte model should
perform very similarly in most titles
now in comparison to the previous budget
Radeon cards running on the polaris
architecture performance is quite strong
overall in project cars - were 24%
faster than the rx 570 12 percent faster
than the rx 580 and 5% faster than the
rx 590 one thing that I'll mention is
that it's quite hard to outright
recommend a card between one of the
better value performers here because in
some cases we are just talking about a
price difference of around $20 we will
compare overall value directly in just a
minute though fortnight chapter 2 showed
a very consistent result with what we've
seen up until this point a slight
performance
just over the rx5 90 and within an arm's
length of the gtx 1660 this is a title
where you most likely won't see a
performance difference between the $170
for gigabyte 5500 XT and the $200 a
gigabyte model there are a couple of
titles that I tested though that did
show some outlier results and despite
reinstalling the drivers and retesting
shut off the Tomb Raider persisted with
some slightly lower performance than the
rx 590 in fact a little worse overall to
the rx 580 so obviously some driver
optimizations need to be done here
otherwise it could just be my test bench
we saw a similar thing with the rx 5700
series launch - similar thing in World
War Z again performance isn't
necessarily bad but it's just not in
line with everything else as we would
expect
I did notice some periodic frame time
spikes in this title - while playing on
the 5,500 XT so good chances are this is
a driver issue
so although performance on average is
slightly above the rx 590 power
consumption is much lower thanks to the
seven nanometer architecture it's more
comparable to the low performing rx 570
still though navi's performance per watt
is a bit worse than what NVIDIA has to
offer here the much faster 1660 Supah
pulls almost the same amount of power
all right now the chart that we've all
been waiting for the average value
directly compared for each GPU so here
we're looking at the amount of money
spent per FPS so the lower value and the
higher ranked each card is on this list
the better value it offers I will note
that this is while including those last
two games with the driver issues for the
lower 5,500 XT performance but still we
have it towards the top of the stack in
terms of value for most of you I would
actually advise the much better value
for gigabyte model unless you're playing
with ultra textures in demanding games
like shadow of the Tomb Raider and Far
Cry 5 also there's no point in buying
the rx 580 or 590 now given the 5500 XTS
release unless you can get them for a
ridiculous price but the RX 574 129 and
sometimes 119 dollars is somewhat in its
own price bracket and still deserves a
recommendation for those on a really
tight budget
I've yet to test the GTX 1650 super
against
the 5,500 XT but given what I've seen
online expect performance to be pretty
much neck and neck between these two
GPUs overall a really solid card from
AMD and I think most people should
probably go for the 4k you might model
juice the better value there and because
most people probably don't use aq bytes
of video memory and will play more
mainstream titles if you were expecting
some overwhelmingly excellent value like
we saw with the 50 750 700 XT that's not
really what we have here
instead the hype s would have been
dampened by the severe price cuts of the
rx 500 series which I don't know how
those cards are still available on the
market today but they are and also of
course the release of the GTX Super
Series from Nvidia so really you've got
a ton of great options now when it comes
to choosing a budget GPU and that's how
the market should be with plenty of
competition so at the absolute bottom
end of the price tag the 129 dollar RX
570 is what I'd personally go for at
$169 I'd bet either the 4 key you buy rx
5500 XT or gtx 1650 super would be a
great choice and beyond that i would
jump straight to the $229 at gtx 1660
super so as always a huge thanks for
watching consider subscribing down below
if you haven't already and i'll see you
all in the next one